hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos
as they come out yeah do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast
this is are you garbage it's a show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day
down here aunt tooty's basement uh ran
upstairs to grab a snack
caught aunt tooty in her nightgown and i
gotta say
the pilates are working girl so [ __ ]
keep it up
tight little body on teddy oh keister on
teddy
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo
of argue garbage ceo c-o-o [ __ ] j-o-o
whatever that is
he does it all so if you're a uh an
investigatory
uh body for the federal government or uh
it starts with three letters keep it
[ __ ] moving
or if you're an asset for the uh state
of ukraine
kevin is the one you want to talk to
kevin james ryan everybody hey what's up
everybody thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube
those numbers are true to [ __ ] roof
their kids are cooking on youtube
oh yeah and then also patreon.com
are you garbage uh guys we're almost at
our our third goal of 600 patrons
uh the support has been [ __ ]
fantastic we're this is a [ __ ]
bootstrapped organization here
it's just the [ __ ] it's a three-man team
and we're doing it all it's the support
of you guys really makes it [ __ ]
happen we appreciate it so much you can
go there you can get bonus content
you can get uh bonus episodes uh are you
garbage every week and get episodes of
hard feelings every week which is just
me and foley [ __ ]
[ __ ] on each other a little bit
behind the curtain uh and then at the
end of every month we do a live stream
with our top tier members
we you get to ask us questions we ask
you questions it's a good [ __ ] time
get involved baby yeah that is it next
one's coming up right
next week i think excited can't wait
shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man he
puts it all together
t-bone toby mcmullen everybody hey what
up there fellas
and gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly incredible
incredibly special guest here with us
today he's a great [ __ ] pal of ours
he's a very funny stand-up comedian
writer director producer and podcaster
okay he's a writer for mostly for
millennials he's been a writer for the f
spot with derek beckles
he was the writer and producer for
danny's house on
what was that on vice i believe vice tv
yeah pretty awesome he has an album out
right now called funnymatic
it's available everywhere and he's also
the new host of the brand new podcast
top nine but the big question about his
mind today
is he garbage and if there was an
episode where i recommend going to get a
box of tissues
because where do you hear this tale of
whoa oh my lord
gang do me a favor give me a nice big
round of applause for my good pal our
good pal
tom cassidy everybody hey
lord it's so good to be here with two of
my oldest friends
comedy happy to have you i was stumbling
on the intro
here in the basement yeah here in
antoni's
ponytail he took care of me i'm not
nervous anymore
gave me a little massage yeah this would
be a place where you would move into
where your parents are working things
out yeah
tony's always cody's always got a brown
couch for you yeah
sleeping out on the sun porch it smells
like burnies
tommy thank you so much for coming in
and sitting down with us oh my lord
thank you for having me we uh we want to
hear the whole story the origin story
obviously we have bits and pieces we've
been friends a long time
go back since moses wore short pants
that's right shout out to uncle junior
uh but what's the what's the complete
tale you're a roxboro kid rock sparrow
trash let's get it out in the open
i'm from an affluent neighborhood that's
the [ __ ] end of the tracks okay
working dead end one way in one way out
roxboro
in northwestern philadelphia the only
neighborhood with a public bathroom
and no park what the [ __ ] we got
gorgeous park what are you kidding me it
sounds beautiful
i got a nice uh monument of course yeah
for the fall and sounds
like that sounds like you gotta expose
the radiation yeah they gotta put the
asbestos somewhere huh
that was very rodney of you yeah
somewhere huh
i'm gonna i'm gonna be a fun one i
literally said hey let's have tommy and
this weekend [ __ ] on him for an hour
[Laughter]
new podcast on come on give it to me
baby he brought the costume for him
thank you shout out the gumby for the
onesie
i thought this was a good beef and beer
outfit you look like a superhero that's
half dressed right
you look like a gay bazooka joke
i got all black on man look at him you
look great mommy c
oh it's so good to you know just mix it
up with the boys
we appreciate coming in i think you we
did do a patreon episode with you early
on
probably about a while ago yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so we do know some of the
back stories what you bitched about
of tommy uh what that he was a patriot
i was also when we had like four people
on the patreon in the big leagues now
baby
thank you for wearing your fancy denim
by the way as opposed to your
white denim jacket that you have thank
god it's not after memorial day yet
tommy called me up after the rhone
episode and was breaking my balls
because uh i was very
i i distanced myself from the show that
we were on with you oh i remember yeah i
heard it no he was like oh yeah we all
did a show together that tom ran me and
foley ran that [ __ ]
always on the flyer yeah fat faces on
the flyer
and a life beater if i recall i think
[Laughter]
hey what was that kid's name that's good
anyway
all right so roxboro kid mm-hmm i have
roots to roxborough as well you
you know some of my family members
played a little league baseball with
stevie ryan yeah shout out to
her went to the movies with him i got a
hand job too i think we went to see
nutty professor
i think it was one maybe two do you
remember that oh
i definitely went to the movies with
kevin's cousin steve ryan my whole times
are just once
say it again multiple times i only
recall them one time
[Laughter]
my dad's whole stuff my dad's whole
family is from roxboro and still a lot
of them still live there
yeah yeah but yeah indians baseball so
we were on the same team
21st award 21st and ward
21st award this is the district of where
i am from
specific it sounds like it's in katrina
wait yeah what wait
there's like different districts in
philadelphia so the 21st award it was
like a baseball
league 21st award the word is a award
like an award
or a award like a like a ward you lived
in the 21st ward
to be honest with you know that you're
asking he's not really really
positive either way you're [ __ ]
trapped i'm ready for it i just struck
out that's all i know
21st ward perhaps i don't know who tells
people what district they live
i'm just trying to be real specific you
asked me some questions over there in
stevens district i live over there
well the neighborhood was uh like
different parts of the neighborhood
different like baseball teams like i was
on the indians like manny unc was like
the tigers
and dora was like uh the orioles so it
was like all different
panthers was little africa there was a
neighborhood in my life i knew you were
gonna go races at some point with that
no there was a neighborhood
like in my neighborhood called little
africa and i think it was just because
like
black people lived on the street it was
only a cultural
five of them probably center no jesus no
they came up with the name of the vfw
after a bunch of warm nickelodeon
so go ahead mm-hmm well you know i went
like i said uh to a
a private school um all of my life
uh holy family from first through eighth
grade archbishop john carroll 9th
through 12th
main line you heard of that yeah yeah
main line lane's got main line's got a
little bit of cage buddy stop trying to
sell it like you were [ __ ]
drinking i'm a fan of the show everybody
kind of like tries to push their garbage
i am garbage so i'm trying to push my
class
you know what i mean lead with catholic
school in philadelphia that'll work
i don't really take it at a time
you got to look through the people ever
so slightly to get to that
wait your school wasn't in philadelphia
proper was that on the main line
that's where you went every day in high
school i went to it was in radner
it was in radner i didn't know that's a
pretty nice area for folks that don't
know did you have to do like
you get the did you take public
transportation or they send the bus
again yeah we had a yellow bus baby but
they would probably pick you up super
early right
pretty early i remember every time seven
thirty
seven years now starting at nine what
are you [ __ ]
wall street traders
[Laughter]
but uh yeah man catholic school i was
just calling it private school to try to
sound classy yeah
we got it i picked up on it um all right
and then
the house that your family lives in now
is that the house you grew up in because
i've been to the outside of that i've
picked you up there i think yeah
yeah yeah were you casing the joints
my parents were down wildwood he was
sneaking through the back window
caught me on the ring phone i hear the
cassies are down the shore in a while
let me slide through and steal some
meatloaf
one thing one thing that struck me is
odd if i could just say
of when i was in cassie there was a
china cabinet in the living room
yeah it's still there i sold to china
yeah no uh so it's got laundry in it
i uh i grew up in the house that my mom
grew up in
is that the house that you're in now i
mean i don't live you know what i mean
but they're still in there that's that's
the house yeah
they live there and they also uh have a
summer home in
north wildwood
which is also owned by anglesey
also very nice which house i've i've
been to that one a handful of times yes
and also i would throw under the bus
last time i was there i went inside to
use the bathroom
and there was a flat screen tv leaning
against them leaning against the dining
room table
probably getting some work done i don't
call that
it's got rabbit ears on it nothing on
that that should have gotten a lot
better by my cat um
wait hold on go back to this thing you
grew up in the house that your mom grew
up in correct
so at a certain point your grandmother
either you got
your parents shipped her off to a home
or something like that how did your
grandma how did your mom
get the house yeah okay so my
mother's mother died when she was young
okay which is something that she talks
about
probably every time you know my mother
she sneaks it in there um when mom
passed by the way she's thinking about
being a patreon
but oh wow well let's all right hold on
let's put a pain in there
i want to bring this up because genie
shout out the [ __ ] genius for the
record we are very close with tom and
his family
i know his parents very i thought we
were very wait a minute why
i thought when she [ __ ] hugs and
kisses me whenever these irish catholic
people are kevin i guess probably did
something to piss her off
which i think so back in the day we we
me we had a podcast with tommy called
center city comedy
and a couple other of our buddies i
actually have all the episodes and i'm
doing a patreon if anybody wants to
jump on that um we had a podcast
and jeannie uh tom's mom was a very big
supporter of us
and yes i guess we recorded at the
shorehouse we recorded it
at said shorehouse next to the flat
screen tv on the ground uh
and i guess at some point
jeannie had a beef with us and
unfollowed
our instagram page really yeah because
we
we switched the center city comedy
instagram page to the uh are you garbage
instagram
she's an emotional woman so she
unfollows us which i didn't know
wait a minute just the not you of your
personal
podcast page okay which is fair enough
i'll never listen again
but then i don't know what happened
because we booked tommy and 20 minutes
later cassidy
follows started following the are you
put your [ __ ]
snakes in the grass oh yeah out there he
must have got the call call
genie was like hey you can follow him
again lift the ban i don't have anything
to do with what that woman does online
are you kidding me i'm not getting into
that hornet's nest
yeah yeah she's also like she's i love
jeannie she's the kind of guy when i
bump into her down the shore i go hey
you know i'm not out it was the middle
of the pandemic i'm like i ain't hugging
[ __ ] slop someone on me real quick
shot a gucci
the old credit card swipe no she's a big
fan
of uh both of you so is my father
motorboat you on the boardwalk
by the way also the last time i saw your
dad was at rest in peace the chris
cotton funeral
but he just walked up to me holy [ __ ]
foley's getting fat huh
why are you talking about it he was
wearing a leather vest by the way i just
want to point that out
it matches the jacket he was wearing a
leather vest
or he was wearing a leather jacket to a
funeral
either either way good leather you were
in sweatpants what are you talking about
that wasn't joggers
totally had a wife beater on all right
so back to the house
so your mom's mom passes away when she's
young mm-hmm okay
and then uh my grandfather passed away
when i was like one or two
so i think he was there and then i think
he died and then my mother
you know took so long still
i think my dad i think my mom and my dad
look at that state taxes
collected in the social security too got
checks on the 15th daddy okay
you just missed them yeah i'm gonna
went out to get milk again for the 15th
time so you put baby powder in tommy's
hair
yeah tell him he's an old man what's
that now
tommy put this blanket over your leg
but uh yeah you know he was a war
veteran um rest in peace
we uh we once read uh his correspondence
from world war ii
on our old podcast i think we might have
i think i remember that my uncle got
really mad at me for that um
mad at the family but anyway he was a
war hero god bless prisoner of war
yeah um i feel like tommy became
autistic at some point during
during this podcast um
but yeah man uh so my mom had a
big family yeah uh i think four brothers
and sisters
my father is from the delaware county
area
also had uh hillary sisters
so just a delco kid meeting a roxborough
gal if you know what i mean
yeah i believe they met in a bathroom
at a bar it wasn't the white house
it was the capitol building it was last
wednesday thomas whole family is down
delco sharpening knives listening to the
podcast
there's gonna be there's gonna be a
couple of [ __ ] dirt balls that are
upset about this one
yeah all right so what else
and what do you want to know what do you
you've seen the show sure
so brothers and sisters you have a you
have a
traditional brother and sister you have
half brothers and sisters i know yes
it's not nuclear in the sense of nuclear
family i'm the same way
i'm the product of a second marriage
if that's what you're asking if that's
what you're getting at
a couple of wrong turns you know me and
my brother and sister all came out of my
mother
so i never really thought of them as my
half brother and sister but there was
another there was another guy before
your dad
correct nice that's how that works yeah
do you know him
a little bit he messages me on facebook
i need money politically i heard you
doing ayg
i can follow him again now huh
i was thinking about joining a patreon
ah
that's good stuff um but yeah i mean i
don't have like a relationship with that
man uh really but
i love a fair spark up between you your
mom and your dad is that was that what
happened with the matter with the first
marriage
no they uh and i'm not being
disrespectful i'm asking you know i love
your mom and dad
sure um but uh i love you genie
um they're watching uh but uh oh i know
i'm gonna get messages after this
for sure um no i think their marriage
didn't work out and then my father came
probably soon after that because i know
they were seeing each other
um before they you know
had me and got married seven months
before i was born
here the shotgun's clicking
i got call up d'allesandros we're
throwing a party uh
straight from the rectory to the [ __ ]
hospital huh squirt this kid out
i got engaged recently yeah
congratulations congratulations
thank you and i asked my mom how she got
engaged and she was like i think i said
that i was pregnant and he was like okay
let's get married
oh man if that's not [ __ ] blue-collar
philly i don't know what it is
all right the romance was in the air
that night i'm in the union i got the
bennies let's do it uh-huh
so yeah there's that um i mean you know
i got
uh i know a few different languages i
speak spanish and french
you do not no you do not you might you
might speak kitchen spanish you don't
speak french tommy
we oh you got us oh [ __ ]
no i mean you know roxboro is a
neighborhood full of demons straight
from hell
that's what we're looking for give us
the juice tomcat i mean it's how young
when
you started selling pills
like 10th grade i think i gave it to
some to chris cromey rest in peace
uh good kid from my high school uh he
was dead
uh but i always thought he was a nice
kid
the chromium state's gonna be coming
after us
the crimean state now he's a good kid uh
but i mean you know so i grew up in
roxbury i went to high school in a
you know a nice neighborhood so i mean i
had that i was exposed to
you know the suburbs too so
it was both of those things ying and
yang i think it's called you know what i
mean
sure yeah all right let's play a little
are you garbage all right let's get into
this
we're going to ask you a series of
questions okay to determine look we know
do you honestly do you think you're
garbage
no do you know your garbage i think it's
the better question
i think it's all about perspective to be
honest [ __ ] lipstick on a pig if you
catch my drift
it really is how you look at it i mean
to someone
do you want the way i look at it is your
trash to some
absolutely you were born with that
i tried to wear you know represent
philadelphia you know i got the eagles
green uh
i mean some people would say so sure but
i don't want to just say i'm garbage
right now at the top
okay okay let's see you know we'll find
out how you live well the shotgun
wedding didn't do you any favors either
i went to europe in high school
all right well let's start off i went to
university let's start off with that
how old were you when you got your
passport i was like 15.
that's pretty [ __ ] good not bad
better than me you wanted a school trip
to europe
yep where'd you go i went the works baby
two weeks in europe we went
to uh we started out grillo tours my mom
died did i tell you that my mom's with a
little bit everyone's going on a pirillo
tour
shout out to pirillo yeah she's like
i'll get the vaccine if i can go on a
cruise
that's right essential healthcare
workers and then the pillow people
yeah that's crazy you got a bunch of
mouth free breathers that want to go to
rome
taking a cruise right now you got to be
nuts yeah that's
crazy uh we went to france
then we went to barcelona spain and then
we went to
parts of italy this is a school trip
yeah that's pretty that's pretty
impressive two weeks pretty fully went
to a sock factory
still got the socks free trip
for school no you got to pay no it
wasn't free probably like two
two g's fifteen hours would you dig that
money out something like that
my dad had it little slip and fall
i'm sure you were the last kid to pay to
go you were probably on the phone she
showed up
he showed up to the airport with the
check
hey don't catch it until we land i was
on a
i was on a layaway program
[Laughter]
to get to europe tommy's had to jump
put him down below he don't need to he
don't need it he don't need a soda on
the right over either
all that fancy oxygen get him in there
pressurized cabin [ __ ] his dad was the
only
parent asking for the cash price
now do i get a six percent discount
pretty good
it's not bad hey gang want to take a
quick second to talk about our new
sponsor stamps.com
let's face it taking trips to the post
office is probably not how you want to
spend your time
it can be a hassle and tiresome that's
why i recommend stamps.com
stamps.com allows you to ship mail
anytime anywhere right from your
computer it's
easy you can ship letters packages and
pay a lot less with discounted rates
from usps and ups and more
i ain't talking just those and more
stamps.com
has saved businesses thousands of hours
and tons of money
with stamps.com you get the services of
the post office and ups
all in one place plus you get the
savings what's not to love
stamps.coms brings services of the us
postal service and ups right to your
computer it's a must-have for any small
business i know a lot of our listeners
are small business owners
it's easy to do you sign up they send
you everything you need and you start
doing it
right from your house or your office if
you got a warehouse if you operate out
of your car wherever you are
stamps.com is right for you with
stamps.com you can get discounts up to
40 percent i ain't talking 10
i ain't talking 20 i'm talking 40 of
post office rates and even more
with ups shipping rates up to 62 percent
off with ups
what's their not well what's there not
to love about that you know what i mean
so stop wasting time
go to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
garbage that's garbage baby name of the
show
g-a-r-b-a-g-e you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
sign up they send you the stuff you need
it's easy
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page
and type in garbage g-a-r-b-a-g-e
that's stamps.com promo code garbage
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
now back to the show how much was it do
you remember
it's a couple grand like kippy said it
was pretty good it was
anything like that it was this you don't
have a passport
still it took you to get some milk just
shut up
hey tubby just snickers and pipe down
with you there's some water you're not
going anywhere
let's put this twix with your brother
but it was uh it was the summer before 9
11.
so it was you know right before that it
was a different time it's wide open back
then
yeah whatever you wanted yeah it really
was uh but i mean
it's pretty good you know travel in the
world going to europe at 15
that's not bad that's your school
keeping you yeah you know that that's
the school pushing you yeah i got in
trouble
one day i couldn't go to the french
riviera because there was like guys like
bothering girls in our like group and we
were like eating and there was like a
glass window
and these guys were like trying to like
come on to them and i
pointed my knife at them to like tell
them to get away
and then like a teacher saw and then i
couldn't go to the beach the one day ah
what the [ __ ] you're sticking up for the
group
yeah i know that's what i said a bunch
of french creeps coming yeah that's dude
that's how the friends do
thanks a lot miss panusi miss panusi
yeah miss panusi can i go to the
bathroom no it wasn't hershey's
threatened people with a butter knife
that's
that's cool hey listen here you frog hit
the bricks
give me a roxboro handshake
take you down to alessandro you should
give you a wiz win a roxboro handshake
is pointing a butter knife at someone
oh god but uh so you know it was a good
time i remember
i do remember my dad getting mad that uh
my airplane soap from
three grand i paid for this kid the
flight's delayed yeah did the weight for
me a little bit i remember getting uh
what do you mean picking you up he
yelled at him he was like what the [ __ ]
he was mad that the plane was coming
back so there's a dichotomy he sent me
to europe but then he got mad at me
because the plane was late
my mom last night i ain't paying for
parking he's just circling for four
hours
this is an emotional time in my family
being on ayg you know they've been
separated from you guys for a little bit
i heard from my mother last night i
heard from my
dad today they're like i feel like
they're here right now yeah
it's a bit it's a big opportunity for
all of the casualties to be on ayg it
really is
his mom's gonna be at the [ __ ] shop
right later today now when will our
episode end
[Laughter]
you heard todd she's gonna
take the mom and wreck him for a drink
she's gonna be back i'm gonna be on
television
my mom was emotional as [ __ ] last night
why she told me that uh
she got a bad mozzarella snack
she she was like i feel really bad that
we yelled a lot when you were little
i was like you're just realizing this
now yeah and then she told me that she
lit 15 candles down at the basilica when
i
had my first uh interview for a writing
job that i got oh man
biting candles down at the basilica
15 all the saints kipping not just at
one little place you went all over the
[ __ ] church
patron saint of bozos
[Laughter]
patrons saying a mediocre comic st marty
dear saint marty forgive me for i have
sinned
my son is a new job oh my lyrics
all righty so you know
our parents did yell a lot when they
were kids but i see you [ __ ] up me and
him went the other way
you went quieter you're not like we're
the hot heads out of the three of us
like you're you have a different
personality than me and foley
you're more reserved you don't lose it
we
we match that you went the other way you
know i think tommy got hit harder
um i think his spot
i don't know man shut up tommy
he wets himself i think sometimes i he's
under the coffee table
this is a stepmom porno i'm stuck shout
out to stockport
[Laughter]
it's a big market those ladies keep
dropping their rings in the garbage
disposal i get caught in the garage door
i told you guys you should flip these
cameras just to this side and start
shooting some of them
make a little more extra money that's a
different kind of patreon time's going
off when you walked in
looking around tommy asked me at the
insurance is paid on this place
somewhere in south jersey is a guy going
i invented stuck porn yeah and i ain't
getting none of that game
before it was cool yeah i think i have a
boiling point but i think i don't reach
it as much as i used to i think i used
to get like
more like yelling back but i don't know
sometimes i sometimes it comes out
but i mean compared to like you guys i
would say yeah
probably you're just more subject yeah
we we we're just following in the past
you you
in the to do the right thing you went
the other way to be more calm and more
subdued
you won't yell at your kids the way our
parents might have yelled at us
i hope not i yelled at foley the way i
was yelled at for sure
oh yeah i'm looking forward he's brought
it out in me though oh yeah no no of
course i'm just saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you have a you
have a higher boiling point than
me and you turn the other cheek okay
i'll take it
which is very respectful i got another
one for you it's pretty classy what'd
you get on the edge it was pretty classy
what'd you get on the sats
it's interesting you say that i um 11
40. me too
yeah and i hit it yeah yeah yeah in my
mind i think i got a 12 30 for some
reason
when i lie i think i say 12 30 but i got
an 11 40.
huh did good on verbal
really what was the hospital you were
born at roxborough memorial
okay
[Laughter]
i could see you being a backseat kid
like on the way to the hospital or
something like that what do you mean
like a bust being born oh yeah my mom
says
my grandpa who died when i was like one
he um he would always
like park out front of our house and
like drop off the milk before he would
find a spot
and my mom said that he was the one who
for some reason had me in the hospital
and he like dropped me off from the
hospital like a gallon of milk
you like marks and uh i think you guys
they're bad nursery rhymes
and since then tommy's been a little
gallon of milk
oh my god i never expired a crazy old
man dropped off the baby
i think you got half the story i think
that was the orphanage
they traded you for a gallon of milk or
something something's going on
instead of a historic it's an oberweis
delivery guy
uh what do uh what's the name of
uh the supermarket genie shops at uh
they got it's gotta be acme acme got it
shoprite
super fresh yeah yeah hitting all you
she knows what she's doing
you kind of hit it you kind of hit the
trashy version that we don't really we
never really brought up
people in philly can turn acme into two
syllables the accommodation
you kind of you stumbled on the a acme
accommodate well my headed down to the
accommodation
yeah um well my dad worked like the
accommodate warehouse down
by where uh called dragon
down by where all the sports all the
perks sure yeah in south philly
so that was his job that he had for many
years working at acme so we were acting
me in that sense but my mom
went to super fresh when they were on
the outs i guess dude genie plays a
fight
so you don't [ __ ] around if you cross
genie she'll [ __ ] cut down what have
you done for me lately i don't know
where loyalties lie
but yeah man super fresh all the job
right not too shabby middle of the road
program and you know wawa for sure as
well you know
what do you mean level we got that big
wah wow uh in roxboro now but there was
the original wawa when i
coming off when i was like six or seven
your mom wouldn't
they're known to have a turkey bowl for
dinner every now and then you know
really
why i love wawa man we believe you yeah
he don't seem like a michelin star kind
of guy i got the sweater from wow
wait a minute hold on okay she wouldn't
no no parent
shops at the convent wawa the
convenience store
it's not like she was getting like lunch
meat from there and stuff like that back
in the day we would
back in the day that was like you would
order at the no generally not though no
just grab something for dinner on the
way home yeah some milk
all right what's your go-to wah-wah
order me i like uh
an italian just a little bit of weight
fabricio like a meatball too you know
five eight italian cold meatball warm
baby
not too bad yeah it'd be weird if you
were eating cold meatballs that's for
sure well i wouldn't be surprised what's
your nickname in kylie
shout out to cold meatballs yo guys cold
meatballs on the way
[Laughter]
all right let's uh let's do this um what
do you got what do you got for him big
man do you have any members of your
extended family doesn't matter who it is
that was any type of local magician
clown anything like that
no i don't believe i can't think of any
local magicians or clowns in my family
any mummers in your family no i don't
think any mummers either i believe my
father's father was like
he had he i think he was like a dancer i
think he like danced chippendales
shout out to the cave on delaware
[Laughter]
he was like a tap dancer i believe and
like did stuff like that i think
my father's father was like someone who
was somewhat in
that the world yeah the show business a
little bit but he was a teacher
okay it could have been that good no
no have you ever worn axe body spray
briefly i would say and you know college
was a different time
they came on with a heavy marketing
campaign that you were like i gotta give
this a shot oh yeah
covered up everything yeah [ __ ] weed
smell pit smell
didn't matter i think we just have to
come to the realization that like
when we were growing up it was different
you know
i think everything is like when
entourage was on tv and when it wasn't
like it was a different time it was it
really was
so i mean you can take it or leave it
but uh it was different
entourage reference that's [ __ ] just
a different time man that's how i base
life
off of when entourage was on tv and when
it wasn't
pre queens boulevard
[Laughter]
i am henry avenue vinnie chasing the
boys
anybody in your family driving isuzu oh
man they only existed in the commercial
oh
[Laughter]
yikes dude if you got an uncle richie
there's no way he's married
he actually just got remarried actually
shout out to remarried for uncle richie
hey man yeah they're all pulling for him
trash only only trashy people use the
term remarried yeah i
got remarried second marriage that's how
people would say i would just think i'm
married
yeah people just say got married i got
remarried
richie shout out to richie what's he do
uh he's in he works for villanova
that was vague not in the engineering
department
more of a custodial position
no no no villanova's probably pay some
bucks though yeah he's in like computer
[ __ ] stealing them yeah come on nothing
on the steel and again you're killing me
here we're trying to peg these
take these dirt balls down what are you
getting against my uncle richie yeah do
nothing to nobody
that sounds like a nice guy he didn't do
nothing right she never hurt you
take it easy mickey does anyone in your
family refer to jeans as dungarees
[Laughter]
no i don't think so my dad is big on the
dungarees what about referring to pants
as slacks
i don't believe so no we're still we're
a big dungarees and slack
oh yeah yeah we're just happy when my
dad put some on
doesn't matter what you call it my mom
used to call something i don't know if
it was pants or jeans but
they were called chinos parachinos
what's chinos chino is i think a
cut brand i believe nah cause like gab
you get a pair it might have been a
brand at one point but i think it was
like a type of khaki like a pair of
chinos
okay yeah um you can't fit in them one
way
i don't know what they are i just know
you can't wear them um
i got it i got a quick one have you ever
used the phrase
that's how they get you and if you have
how what is it that is how they get you
you know i think
um the further i get away from
philadelphia i feel like
like longer i've like not lived there i
think i did say stuff like that
um that's how they get you um probably
like a cop
like pulling you over for a dui or
something like that you said
you say god bless a lot i noticed that i
do say god bless you hang up god bless
you so like i have two nephews
as well and my brother has a child oh
lookers by the way one kid's got a body
on him
he's scrolling through that instagram
the other day
kid works out he's a boxer an mma fight
or something yeah he would [ __ ] you up
tommy oh they both would he would
he kill all of us whatever he's not my
nephew i'm just the guy on the street
i treat him like a pokemon too much of
drinking his mouth
at christmas he can work you next to the
[ __ ] tree
[Laughter]
that's funny my uh no my nephew ryan
who is the other one who's another hot
piece they're looking kids oh my god
like butter but uh he says stuff like
that's a sin
so like that's like that's right that's
that catholic that's that
that that irish catholic yeah he's like
a 21 year old kid god bless he's saying
that's a sin
what is he sounds like something auntie
would say yeah and does
that's a sin so i mean there's
definitely that level
ever have season tickets to uh g-league
basketball or triple-a baseball
anything like that you ever go to the
miners nah trenton thunder nah
nah nah no i mean i went to a lot of
sporting events uh growing up but we
would usually scalp tickets
dad can we get tickets beforehand nah
nah that's how they get you tommy
first we gotta find parker yeah we
scaled a lot of tickets
really but yo i mean you would go down
to a game with your family
with probably just me and my dad or like
me and my dad and my friend or something
like that
you kids wait here i'm going to go get
tickets no bring us with him what do you
wouldn't
yeah wait up with us on the corner go
for the sympathy price
tommy stop trying to tell one of you to
start limping
be sure i want to see randall cunningham
but yeah you know mike schmitz playing
today we'd roll through
probably like first or second inning you
know what i mean while the game was
already started
but you know i've seen some great games
like i speaking through the sewers
tommy hold your breath ocean's eleven
cassidy's three sneaking in the bowels
of the vet
wait hold on i assume that your dad
would be the kind of guy to pay for one
seat
and then try to push his luck to get you
down as close as possible
he was a uh he was a shifty man
always looking for a bargain he's a
grifter
that's really what it is you're from a
family of grifters
oh yeah the whole lot of yous perhaps
none of them were shooting you straight
genie gave me even gene genie gave me a
hug she took my wallet
[ __ ] [ __ ] pack of gypsies over
that's what i've been trying to get out
for the last 37 minutes go back like
pulling teeth with this
go back to your shandy he definitely was
looking for a deal
drinking snake bites you're watching the
game he's setting up three card monty by
the nachos like i feel like [ __ ]
magners cider on the front porch trash
that's why i was a little hesitant at
first i knew we'd get here eventually
you want to give it all away in the
first five minutes tommy was playing
prevent defense uh-huh
meanwhile she's going out the door let's
go get to the dirt please got the nickel
um he would always just try to save
money in any way that he could
so like i feel like even when he didn't
work at acommy warehouse we would park
there
so we didn't have to
i know the security guard it's all right
but to be fair closer to the stadium
about two miles
man it wasn't too bad it was probably
you know it was a walk but it was it's a
hike it's it's in the same neighborhood
but it's a hike
probably like a 12-minute walk something
like that as a little kid but there's
always be like a reasoning like well
now we don't have to wait for the like
get caught in like the traffic of the
parking oh yeah there's always reasoning
behind
everything you know and i saw some great
games man i was at the uh
sixers game where alan iverson crossed
over michael jordan that's one of the
greatest
philadelphia sporting events under the
bleachers but still
we were up there but it was still you
know
you guys posted this maintenance man in
the [ __ ] camera
tommy's got a fake mustache and only six
hey we're here to check the boiler
tommy put a belt on act like you're in a
union let's go
here's this broom just sweep in place uh
anywhere with a clipboard i swear to god
in a [ __ ] hard hat so you know
there's uh you know
we'd be there dressed like the [ __ ]
ymca
the what i'm trying to what's the who's
who sung ymca i got those people the
village people i got this song and not
the group
that's okay they all show up as
different occupations
[Laughter]
tommy's in handcuffs is that exactly
what he's arrested him
i got everybody's punk down in the
basement i caught this scalper now
that's a deep cut
come on it's pretty good
okay oh man you i don't know how we got
there but you're a family
nonetheless
[ __ ] three-card monty all the time
probably can't trust anybody you know
[ __ ] guns out knives we're a sleight
of hand thing
you can't have razor blades on their
hats instead of taking off your shoes
when you walk in the house you gotta
empty your pockets
no blades no bows check your weapons
here
we got an ordinance in this town
make sure you go through the metal
detector before you hit the rumpus room
kids
all right we're having fun now we're
cooking baby
yep um never go to the liquor store with
the specific reason of
asking for boxes no oh dude
that's so funny you bring that up my
that's a pat that's right another
[ __ ] patty foley handbook yeah dude
go to that like the acme you got any
boxes uh
my aunt who's like she was an executive
for a very big company very well that
she was moving and she asked my brother
to help her and she's like
well can you go try to find some boxes
my brother's like i'll buy the [ __ ]
boxes lady
i'm not going to the store to ask some
schmuck for boxes
you're loaded what are we doing here
yeah uh that's real trashy because kippy
your family is
a drinking family oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um you've heard correct the word on the
street yep all
right they weren't that big of drinkers
that wasn't really
you know uh you know my mom definitely
had some screwdrivers
that's what was her drink was a
screwdriver get a little loose lift get
smacked around a little but uh
start running her mouth about uncle
richie
[Laughter]
uh but they weren't like big drinkers
really no
yeah no you don't have to be a big
drinker to go to the liquor store to get
boxes you got to be trapped
if that wasn't i wasn't thinking they
were picking up a bottle of [ __ ] rio
needy on ice
oh i guess i just think of people who go
to the liquor store for things that
aren't liquor
could probably also be alcohol i figure
they're getting the boxes so they can
also get a
bottle of vodka as well okay good
argument have you ever saved a cigar box
for storage
uh that's a real do you open up
someone's like top drawer there's a
cigar box
with like you know a pocket knife some
some euros or something
there's always a patch in there too a
nice pack a necklace from like the 80s
yeah i think i was given one like a like
a lion one because i'm a leo
okay um
so yeah i did have one of those i don't
have it anymore but yeah probably out of
college
at a lion guard case yeah that was a big
like first place you get on your own you
got a cigar box in your hand like
on the nightstand with condoms and
trinkets keep all your stuff and keep
your weed in there keep your lube in
there
have you ever done a shot out of a shot
glass that was attached to a beaded
necklace
probably in college yeah yeah for sure
what about one of those boards i see
people doing shots on those boards
like everybody does it yeah yeah that's
like real that's real party [ __ ] that's
trash
yeah if so maybe i mean when you're
partying whatever if you're [ __ ] up
and you're just trying to get more
[ __ ] up
i don't care what you're thinking again
entourages on tv it's 2006.
you know sure yeah yeah it's a magazine
you have any maximum magazines and
i think i had uh the one hot like
lindsay lohan
maxim cover on like my wall in college
yeah that's another that's a question
i've had on the list have you ever cut
stuff out of a magazine and put on your
wall
real dirtball [ __ ] i definitely did that
in college i did it in high school
shout out to terry hatcher oh man
when desperate housewives dropped loves
her i also love jamie lee curtis they're
real and they're spectacular
by the way people love the deep cut
seinfeld references yeah yeah
excellent hey regis relax
oh you went in the [ __ ] daytime host
right there yeah okay great moving on
just came out getting tommy's stink on
me i don't know what it is
by the way whatever window or something
but whatever meat you ate before is
coming out of your pores
that dog food that he had the kale salad
i'm catching whips at kobe beef or
whatever
you tell me i got to eat right i eat
right now you're good yeah i mean right
before the podcast
well i need to keep on my meal track
otherwise my blood sugar gets low and
then i'm all luffy and goofy oh here we
go i think you could spare to lose a
meal or two yeah
tommy let me ask you this please now
this covers any member of your family i
don't care who it is
but your [ __ ] mom your dad if it's a
cousin you see
once a year have any of you cassidy's
or wax that's another thing that's a
good wait
what my mom's maiden name is whack
i knew that shout out to genie yeah i
knew that too
also there was a weird thing at a time
where you two might be related
yes migraines that was quelled very very
quickly
what do you mean quilt by my parents
lawyers squash that
real quick jacoby and meyer
i'm not splitting up a [ __ ] above
ground pool 12 ways
uncle richie's coming over in the summer
he's swimming in club foley
that's enough uncle richie he's gonna
get pissed the man's been through enough
[Laughter]
no on my mother's side her father uh
on uh his aunt's death bed she told him
that
uh his mother had an affair with a fully
[ __ ] shyster fat guy short hair cool
jean jacket
so there's a possibility that that's a
very that's a very trashy thing
deathbed confessions oh yeah i know bear
with a foley i know i'll have a couple
waiting huh
i skipped a couple meals when i found
that out dude a favor of the foley you
[ __ ] you take that to the grave
you don't you don't let that thing out
of that that was like oh i found out
about hell
it's like the scene and crying game
crying in the shower
uh if i need a blood transfusion i'll
give you a call any of your family
members ever appear on
antiques roadshow
trying to hack an old vase or something
trying to honk an old football phone
did i did
uh here we have a
steven whack here we got a 42 year old
dirt ball with a
garfield alarm clock we'll uh check the
date on this my aunt donna has her
entire house i believe is filled with
just knickknacks i don't think you can
like move
without a knick-knack uh stepping on
nicknacks yeah
knickknacks got to a point where it's
too much she's got a lot of knickknacks
what was your question before that
uh thank you tommy uh i just thought i'm
sorry i appreciate it no
have you or any member of your family
ever appeared on the local news
for any reason at all i was on dino fest
i believe in 1997.
i'm sorry dino fest what's that it was
like uh
it was a dinosaur exhibit of like bones
and stuff and they interviewed me as my
first television credit
cause i saw your teeth
it's funny it was great timing and
rhythm but i don't get the joke it's
these things they were dinosaurs
okay it wasn't jeannie was just on the
news not too long ago
my mother and my father i believe my
uncle richie as well they were they were
posing like they did the tonight show
they uh here in the green room
just the parking lot talk to local wacko
they were on the uh local news for
here we have three local bozos they're
gonna tell us exactly what they saw
they were at uh they're blaming each
other having a screwdriver
ah by the bio business he's yelling at
me look look look look
finally i turn around and say shut the
hell up i'm having a drink oh genie's
gonna get so busy
that the real reason why i am trash is
that like
all of my like my parents are gonna
watch this and [ __ ] at me sure
like a lot of people's parents that do
the show aren't gonna watch the [ __ ] or
care what the [ __ ] they say on a goddamn
podcast i'm going to hear about this
[ __ ] that's what makes it so much
funnier is
because it's like danger we're making
fun of we're [ __ ] on genie i love
jeannie i want to see her
she's a classy lady down the line hey i
love my parents
back to the local news staff they were
featured
on uh they had a guest starring role
abc uh no uh they were at the
uh villanova uh championship basketball
parade i think they sneak into that
i mean it was on the street what was
that griff
they're all dressed up like a sitting
shoes
i swear to god i was a water boy they're
watching from a tree like angels in the
outfield
no i'll have you know that my father
attended villanova university thank you
very much
a work release program
next question uh
wait what was that yeah tell us about
that i remember because you i remember
posting it on facebook oh and they won
the championship they were at the parade
for villanova i don't know they're in a
good time you know
they found the cameras published yeah
that's what he thought it was girls
going wild have your parents ever
attended a parade they love a good
parade
they love parades for sure saint
patrick's day over the candy
they throw out there's never a parade
guy oh
parade love a good parade when the
phillies won come on
that was okay dad i stay away from those
i
was perfect time dude i was i was 21 the
[ __ ] sure you get a school bag full
of beers
put a 30 pack in a school bag and just
[ __ ] go out i meant like a proper
parade i always thought i'm not going to
the fourth of july parades oh they were
brutal because i always wanted to give
me a sixer and a [ __ ] roman candle
call it a knight
people always makes you up for the
garfield float
he's off his shrinks shoot him
three shriners coming right toward us
garfield floats coughing they used to go
around with that shopping cart that had
all those toys in it remember
like they were able to collect toys they
were like blow up toys
do you guys want to talk the hammer and
the baseball bat yeah all the i used to
i see that and go nuts oh yeah of course
would never let me [ __ ] i couldn't go
near that thing
the difference between me and you was i
got whatever i wanted off that yeah
my dad was like my dad my dad would be
like 50 bucks i'll shut him up for an
hour keep it moving
yeah you can have it right there and
have his smart breads and he's got a bb
gun in there
he got a bb gun in a dinner roll to shut
this fat little bastard up
don't stop asking questions i'm not even
sure if he's mine
um okay good stuff
um tommy you prefer cocoa puffs or cocoa
pebbles because there's a right answer
here
i'm gonna go coco pebbles man good job
buddy
i prefer fruity though to be honest with
you ever appeared on a company website
for any reason
have i yeah like a picture like of you
like working or anything like that yeah
i believe
uh my one job out of college uh i worked
at a place called compass north reality
where i was a property manager
for temple students i got a question
about that job and section eight tenants
and stuff i
had like 400 tenants that were i was
deserving of contact who i believe i was
section eight in there real quick didn't
you
hey listen uh they were something else
uh but uh
you're trying to make it sound like you
were the ceo of merrill lynch
no i was just saying the job that i had
but um i was on that
fair enough i apologize um this is from
uh pedro
we always do it real quick we always do
a couple patreon questions and since
you're talking about that this is from
ben
he asked me because he goes to temple
and he knows i went to temple he said
were you a maxis or a draft horse kind
of guy
hey ben thanks for the question uh it
was more directed to me but i was
passing it off to you yeah take it easy
frazier
i get them a little mixed up but i think
maxie's uh actually this was the pizza
place like on
only a course right next to the 7-eleven
and the draft horse was uh
draft horse used to have dollar beers
that you could use your diamond dial
like your campus box draft which was
like the bar
yeah the proper bar and restaurant yeah
i thought that was nice that was a good
time
definitely took a few interns there oh
yeah um
and uh i like both of them for different
reasons yeah i think i got the buffalo
chicken at max
the buffalo chicken slice of maxi's was
a [ __ ] shout out i mean the
cheesesteak
oh that was sandwich it was pretty good
and draft horse was good too yeah both
shout out to benny to you baby gun to my
head i'm going maxis my man all right
let's talk about this let's talk about
now let's let's see
if you know the upbringing nature versus
nurture
what you're like now what do you go to
the grocery store now
i go to the grocery store across the
street from me
um from my house i think it's like just
a neighborhood
grocery store what's it called i don't
even know
associated or probably something like
that that's not good
yeah names howl a fresh grocer i don't
[ __ ] know
how old were you when you stopped going
to the pediatrician
were you like one of those kids that
went through you're supposed to stop
going
i i used to go to the future when i
could drive by the way oh absolutely i
went up until college yeah shout out to
dr rogers i i'll uh the last time i
don't have a doctor
now because my last doctor was shout out
to doctor endo
last doctor was your pediatrician yeah
um i feel like i stopped going to my
pediatrician
when i was like 18 probably yeah i
believe
fair enough fair enough i also
feel like my doctor was just when i was
growing up was just a doctor i don't
like a proper belief it was a
pediatrician i don't think i ever had a
child doctor
you had dwarfs were you going to [ __ ]
a guy
and my mom went to the same doctor same
guy really good pap smear
tommy's legs up in the stairs
do you currently owe anybody any money
no i mean besides like credit card debt
but
not too much of that doing okay we don't
gotta [ __ ] open the books like that
do we
jesus christ cut that
i got a couple of bucks on the street
yeah what do you want from me none yeah
no i don't okay
foley uh owed me i think 300
once for i think three years yeah it was
awesome you paid them back
yeah i think eventually got it mm-hmm
no vig i had settled with my debt
collector
even gave him 222. i used to have a joke
about he's like you don't need it right
now
that's what he used to say when you need
it yeah i'll give it to you
which is like he was waiting for my life
to fall apart to give me the three
hundred dollars
we've seen the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i just remembered it it's been a while
since i told that joke it's old school
but
okay no debts um anyone in your family
ever owned a non-working car
i had them in a car parked out on the
street yeah definitely i think my dad
had a mustang
that i mean it was a pretty nice car but
i mean know it definitely went in and
out
do you remember what year the mustang
was i believe it was in 1995 henry wow
that was a good
black but that's really true that's was
like it's a while ago though when he had
it it wasn't like an antique it wasn't
like he had like a 66 mustang
yeah but they were the new bodies that
came out it was kind of like a special
um two memories do you remember when it
was parked and didn't work
um no i mean like out of college
so what year are we talking about i feel
like the more we talk about this the
more my accent is coming out
like out of college um i don't even talk
like you hide that trash
it comes oozing out um but uh yeah like
i don't know 2010
2011. what are you a detective i don't
know well i'm just saying the 50 you're
talking about how great the car is he
just said it was quite it was great in
like compared to a [ __ ] gto or
something it was just like it was a nice
car wait what year are you saying
2008 hey listen you don't even have a
car
why does it matter when it was [ __ ] i
don't know
at some point it was not running
but it was like an antique almost it was
20 years old can i talk to you for a
minute yeah i don't know what you're not
wrapping your head around what's going
on it was an older mustang he was trying
to fix that
95 this isn't an older mustang you know
i believe when he got it at the time it
wasn't too old it was still okay
you know all right if you say so hmm
mustang folks growing up disposable
plates were you guys a paper or
styrofoam household
you peg me i peg you as a styrofoam yeah
i feel like i've like this is the
question that like drives me to insanity
mm-hmm
like thinking about like i don't know
something horrible happening with a
styrofoam plate right now your dad would
be hitting your mom with a snack
or something you dumb rule i think uh i
think we're paper though to be honest
with you
now would you use those for holidays and
stuff or would you have would you use
the
real plates in nice china for for for
hollywood what's the [ __ ] you think we
have the china closet for
laundry hockey pucks weren't there
um but uh i think we used it more for
parties i think generally like maybe if
we got like pizza we'd use paper plates
but generally we used plate plates okay
for dinner that's how trashy is he
called them plate plates
you know like a plate no dishwasher i
don't think i've ever had a dishwasher
really i thought there was a dishwasher
the one
one of the times that i was at your
house okay there was a washing machine
or a dishwasher
on the front porch it wasn't a
dishwasher i'm sweating listen
i'm not trying to be funny i swear to
god why start now
[Laughter]
your dad was redoing the kitchen okay
along with the mustang
he was putting a dishwasher in the
mustang it was proud of the mustang
seats in the kitchen
it was it was probably a washer dryer to
be honest with you they just got a new
washer and dryer shut out
yeah they
you or any of your family members got
into a fight at a little league game
i believe my father was not allowed to
go to some of my little league games
because he would argue with my coach
i believe he was ejected from at least
one game
he was also a coach he coached for a
couple years too but
but he didn't coach you right he coached
no he coached me oh he did yeah
um we won a championship in fall ball
once
because i always saw the 21st award i
always thought it was strange
take it easy i always thought it was
strange that dad that coached but didn't
coach his kids
yeah that's weird yeah pedophile [ __ ]
maybe he's trying to get back to the
community yeah i know my dad coached
with his buddy but his buddy's kid
was on the team we were already we had
already aged out
it's just a weird thing to be a coach
and your child's not on the team for
children it's like
you miss the boat buddy if you want a
coach have a kid yeah what are you doing
like my kid can't handle my style
i would like to jump back real quick a
couple questions about the
washer and dryer if memory serves do you
need to clean a blanket
what room what room is the washer and
dryer in the house i believe it's in the
kitchen
from if i remember oh really do you want
to get the blueprint out
when you were casing it there's no
blueprints for that house
i think didn't go get permanent i didn't
pull any permits on that one that was
done
[Laughter]
the kitchen's in the back and then
there's like a little washroom
on the outside i wasn't being
disrespectful
i love how you're saying that now you
[ __ ] on his mom and his uncle for
[ __ ]
fitness i did you did yeah i'm not i'm
not trying to be respectful
you're coming you're coming to tony
you're getting to eat what do you want
from me
i mean i'm gonna have to hug his mom
until it was all for comedy do what you
gotta do all right baby let's get these
views out
scandals and animals
[ __ ] uncle bob touched me a
few more views huh all right paper plate
uh
let's see let's see let's see uh what
was the longest you ever
went without going to the dentist uh i
feel like i went growing up but i mean i
did need braces and they never i mean i
think i think they probably asked me i
think they were like do you want braces
and i was like no and they were like
okay
same thing with his appendix does it
hurt so bad you got to get it taken out
no i'm all right yeah it keeps fine
let's walk it off
yeah go sneak into a philly's game
put this exterminator
hey kid you know how to drive a zamboni
there's nothing wrong
stop crying you want to see the flyers
or what nothing wrong with supporting
the urban community and catching a ball
game while you're at it
listen but i went to the dentist but uh
when was the let do you go now currently
because i went like a decade without
going yeah i haven't been to the dentist
more than that [ __ ] probably 20 years
yeah i went to the dentist uh i think
like right before the pandemic
okay that's not bad yeah they say i had
a few cavities
had to get them filled um but uh yeah
you know take care of your teeth
everything about getting braces
you know to be honest with you i am
thinking about getting one yeah why not
it's like you can finance it it's like
it's [ __ ] 1200 bucks or so does it
work yeah
what the [ __ ] is that what is this a
commercial for invisalign i don't know i
think it's just promo code garbage
everybody
how does it work tom
well first you steal it from somebody
but uh so yeah
okay um i got a couple from uh the
patreon as you know when you sign up for
patreon we will ask uh
one of your garbage questions just kind
of one way to guarantee
us asking your questions because we get
so many requests each week so when you
sign up we will answer your question
um this is from eddie have you ever had
to share a bedroom with a grandparent
which is a home run of a question piggy
oh that comes from that guy's life yeah
that's a good one
uh or an uncle you know we can extend it
obviously an uncle or something or an
aunt
um no i down at the shore house in wyatt
wood
down the shore is different [ __ ]
that's right now i know like
so my mom and dad had a bedroom and then
like i had a bedroom and then like my
grandmom had a bedroom so there was that
aspect of it
so no how come your sister and your
brother didn't have a bedroom just out
of curiosity um they i mean i guess mine
they were there
or yeah um but i mean that's just how i
refer to it in my mind
but when my sister was pregnant we
shared a room
together um and it was a a bunk bed
so like my sister's putting in a bunk
bed while you're pregnant is not wow
good luck so i don't think it was like
for the whole pregnancy but there was
definitely like a couple months in there
where she was on the bottom bunk and i
was on the top bunk
and i was always worried that i would
like wake because i sleepwalked when i
was a kid
and i was always worried that i was like
he's choking her out
yeah kill my little baby fetus nephew
but yeah so i that's pretty bad tell me
about the sleepwalking
wow that's a tough one there was one
time where i walked
out into the street and a car was coming
and my dad stopped me right before i
walked into the stream
why was he in the street get away from
the mustang he heard me so they knew i
streetwalked so
they knew i was a hooker they knew i was
turning tricks
so they'd always hear for me no i they
knew i sleepwalked so i had lights on in
your room
they heard me walking down the steps
they heard the door open to the
exterior of my house and i walked
outside i think this was like in high
school probably around the time my
sister was pregnant
man cool kid yeah i'm talking about
playing it cool
i don't sleepwalk anymore so that's good
kids trying to run away in the middle of
his [ __ ] sleep so i almost got hit by
a car sleepwalking
um but um yeah um
uh all right i got one or two more here
um i'm just gonna wrap up it's leaning
towards trash
i know it's so funny that i had a goal
of trying to not
yeah you came in here i went to private
school so you got kicked out of public
you went to catholic school
didn't pay full fare i would assume i
worked in the rectory
what's it to you there you go that was
great school
but uh my family didn't like the like oh
my aunt got a job as a secretary at the
prep so all the kids could go there for
free yeah
um all right this is from colin did your
shower get extremely hot or extremely
cold when someone flushed the toilet
kyle that's a great question mine turns
off when someone flushes the toilet i
swear to god the shower stops yours
turns to [ __ ]
uh cold yeah it would go cold yeah ours
went hot
shoddy plumbing uh is that what it is
that what it comes down to it's just
like bad water prep yeah i guess
not i mean well it's not electricity
issue i know that much
my brother's a plumber 690 guy
union guy no next question
i think he did just sometimes he's got
line crossers
no he's [ __ ] russell buffalino
your uncle is an inflatable rat
i heard you paint houses um all right
let's do
a lot of pipes are missing matt's
supposed to be like that
where's all the copper i don't know five
cents for each inch
um but uh all right this is from will we
kind of touched on this at the beginning
um have you ever ordered a beer tube at
a bar
oh god because you think you're real
cool when you do
yeah again man different times college
college was yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely because they
dropped when we were in kotlin because
we're the same age they dropped when we
were in college the thing that looks
like a bong that has a spicket yeah it's
like it has like eight beers in it it's
like two pitchers or something
i remember my when those dropped my
buddy at the bar being like whoa hanging
out and pulling out the calculator
and being like nah these two they're
ripping us off yeah you're paying for
the [ __ ] sizzle
i always thought i always thought a
picture you were getting ripped off no
pictures i never dressed
pictures to the dome good really it's
never a picture guy yeah they ask you
how many gla
like let me get a picture or quote like
whatever was the cheat like coors light
or whatever they're like how many
glasses you need i'm like just one daddy
oh really okay drinking one to yourself
like at a table or just like keep the
pictures coming how much everybody's
drinking
eight nine bucks 10 bucks probably
unless you're in a real
dirt ball [ __ ] bar and they give you
the pitcher and they don't give you any
glasses because they know that
you're going straight out the pitch yeah
yeah i've done that for sure they never
clean those
in that bud light pitcher that's oh he
hasn't spout on oh yeah
that plastic pitcher the clear one that
was always like half being shattered
yeah big fan yeah jake's bar in
westchester
used to they had the nickel beers around
knockback pictures there and then i
would and
when i wanted to get classy i'd go down
the landmark and i'd get one of the
towers that we're talking about if you
think beer towers are classy you're
trash
the towers were for the weekend the
pictures were for the week
i gotta get a stun on the weekends well
i think i have all the information i
need or
i ha i need to render a decision yes 100
grade a with onions roxboro
trash yeah but you knew that
this was this was this was just fun i am
what i am
we love you we know you we know you're
garbage we're garbage yeah
you got a brand new podcast coming out
called top nine with anthony moore
top nine podcast with anthony moore me
and anthony uh it's gonna be weekly it
should come out this week um i don't
know when this comes out but uh so it
should be out when
you hear this but uh we have guests on
um and
they give us their top nine lists in
anything instead of top ten at stop nine
top nine baby number nine baseball
indians that was my number
so you know you guys are free rocks come
on races
do you say that rockstar top nine
podcast tom cassian ants anymore
kippy what do you got for him guys thank
you so much as always please make sure
you rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube and then
again like i said patreon.com you sign
up we'll ask you a question
you get a lot of bonus content and you
help support the [ __ ] show
it's just me and foley ain't nobody
giving us some [ __ ] handouts over
here you know what i mean me foley and
t-bone shout out to t-bone
uh guys at cameron comedy on all social
media at it's fully on ice on twitter
foley graham's on instagram
uh to reiterate what kevin says thank
you very much tommy thank you so much
for coming in and sitting down
thank you tomcat thank you so much i was
a little heavy-handed at times he gave
you a little bit you know what i mean
this was
i've been thinking about this all week
giggling about me and you us
three sitting here chopping it up so
well it's great
here thank you for having me shout out
to totally time
and we love you guys and we will see you
next week